Films can do a great job of taking us inside
the minds of characters.
Martin Scorsese burrows into the warped psyche
of Robert De Niro’s vigilante in Taxi Driver.
In Safe, director Todd Haynes asks us to see
the world through the eyes of Julianne Moore’s
suburban housewife, who may or may not be
going crazy.
And, of course, David Fincher’s Fight Club
fractures a character’s mind so deeply that
by the end we have to re-evaluate everything
we’ve seen.
In 1993, the acclaimed Polish director Krzysztof Kieślowski
released a film that explores
the mental and emotional experience of a woman
grieving her husband and young daughter.
It’s heavy material, but the filmmaking
remains lyrical, expressive, and humane.
So let’s take a closer look at Krzysztof
Kieślowski’s Blue.
[Intro Music Plays]
[intro]
Blue is actually the first film in a loose trilogy.
After making The Decalogue, a collection of
ten short films inspired by the Ten Commandments,
writer-director Krzysztof Kieslowski
decided to make a series of feature films
named after the three colors of the French
flag.
He and co-writer Krzysztof Piesiewicz — and, yes, they’re both named Krzysztof
— mistakenly believed that each color represented
one of the three ideals of the French Revolution:
liberty, equality, and fraternity.
They liked that framework so much that they
stuck with it, even when they learned that
the colors and the motto weren’t directly
linked.
It didn’t matter much anyway, since Kieslowski
wasn’t interested in making explicitly political films.
He’s a deeply humanist filmmaker, and all
his films are notable for their patience,
their emotional power, and their closely-observed
characters.
The stories often examine how universal themes
play out in the intimate moments and day-to-day
lives of humans.
And Blue is Kieslowski’s movie about liberty.
He chose to focus on a character who, in the
wake of a tragic accident, attempts to liberate
herself from all ties to her past, her own
desires, and even the world itself.
Juliette Binoche plays Julie, the
protagonist.
Her husband, Patrice, and young daughter,
Anna, are killed in a car accident within
the first few minutes of the film.
The story then follows her attempts to go
on without them.
And, at first, she almost chooses not to.
While recovering in the hospital from the
accident, Julie tries to kill herself.
She stops, but we immediately understand the
depth and power of her grief.
Back in the world, she resolves to strip all
traces of her family from her life.
She just wants to exist, free from all attachments
— physical, emotional, and spiritual.
She sells most of her possessions and puts
her country estate on the market.
The only thing she keeps is a mobile made
from blue crystals that hung in her daughter’s room.
She collects sheet music for an unfinished
composition her husband was working on, and
throws it into the jaws of a garbage truck.
And she moves to a nondescript apartment building
with no children in it and finds a bit of
peace in her solitary nighttime swims in the
building’s pool.
Her isolation is almost complete.
And yet, the more she tries free herself from
the past, the more it seems to grip her.
A boy who witnessed the crash tracks her down
and attempts to return a necklace he took
from the accident.
Caught off-guard, Julie appreciates the gesture,
but tells him to keep it.
She doesn’t want another physical reminder
of her family.
She’s also haunted by her husband’s unfinished
symphony.
Pieces of it play over the soundtrack at emotional
moments.
And sometimes Julie seems to hear it, as
if it’s surging up from inside her own mind.
She also discovers Patrice has left behind
a very tangible echo of himself.
He had been having a long-term affair, and
his mistress is pregnant with his child.
As it becomes clear that Julie can’t actually
free herself from her memories, she begins
to wrestle with new ways to live in the world.
Reluctantly, she works to complete her husband’s
symphony with his steadfast colleague Olivier,
played by Benoît Régent.
She gives her country house to Patrice’s
mistress, suggesting that her unborn child
should have both Patrice’s name and his
house.
And by the end of the film, she even seems
open to a possible romantic relationship with
Olivier.
Maybe.
Just maybe.
As the complete version of Patrice’s composition
plays at the end of the film, we check in
with each of our major characters, ending
with a weeping Julie who gives a hint of a smile.
It’s one final indication that she might
be healing, even if the hurt will never fully
go away.
At the core of Blue is Binoche’s powerful performance
as her character navigates grief.
She’s in every scene and rarely speaks more
than a few lines at a time.
Kieślowski keeps the camera close to her
face, tracking the emotions roiling inside
her, from despair to tenderness.
And often she embodies more than one of those
conflicting emotions at once.
In the scene where she confronts Patrice’s
mistress, Binoche is somehow able to play
Julie’s hurt and anger, but also her curiosity,
determination, and maybe even envy.
She’s lost her child, and this stranger
is carrying her husband’s unborn son!
Kieślowski and cinematographer Slawomir Idziak also flood the film with the color blue.
Not a huge surprise there… it’s in the
title, after all.
And one way to critique a film is to analyze
motifs that the filmmakers use again and again
to try and understand some deeper meaning.
Whether it’s sunlight refracted through
the blue mobile crystals, or the wavering
hues of the swimming pool, the color seems
to take on different meanings to match Julie’s
emotions.
Writing in The New Review of Film, author
and Kieślowski scholar Steven Woodward observes
that despite the American association of blue
with sorrow, the color is actually the least
culturally defined of Kieślowski’s trilogy.
White commonly represents innocence, purity,
and light, while red often signifies desire,
heat, or anger.
But blue can be soothing or sad, distant or
refreshing, scary or relaxing.
And that makes it the perfect color to illustrate
Julie’s shifting emotions.
When she steps into Anna’s empty room, we
discover its walls are all blue.
Overcome, Julie attacks the mobile, tearing
off some of its crystals.
Here, blue is a prison, a stark reminder of
what she’s lost.
Elsewhere, the color seems to haunt Julie.
Off-screen lights will inexplicably turn blue,
making her look ghostly.
For some shots, Kieślowski and Idziak went
so far as to wrap the entire camera in blue
gels, which are those transparent filters
used in lighting.
Beyond color, Kieślowski uses sound and music
in sophisticated ways to give us a sense of
Julie’s experience.
Most of the music in the film is non-diegetic.
That’s music added to the film to create
meaning or heighten emotion, but it doesn’t
have a source within the world of the film.
In other words, it’s music that the characters
in the film can’t actually hear.
Even though we, the audience, do.
Kieślowski and composer Zbigniew Preisner play with the line between
diegetic and non-diegetic sound to great effect.
When Julie first retrieves the score for her
husband’s symphony, we hear pieces of the
music.
And so does Julie.
Or at least she imagines it, and we get
to listen into her imagination.
And when she throws the sheet music into the
garbage truck, the song distorts as the trash
compactor’s teeth tear the paper.
This extreme use of subjective sound puts
us in Julie’s experience even more fully.
And the opening chords of Patrice’s symphony
haunt Julie throughout the film.
In one early scene, Julie sits alone in a
chair at night, shortly after watching her
family’s funeral through a little TV set.
The opening beats of the symphony blare on
the soundtrack as a bright blue light fills
the room.
Julie looks almost directly at the camera
with a vaguely terrified expression, watching
us as we dolly away from her, and then back
toward her.
Suddenly, Julie seems aware not only of the
non-diegetic score, but also of the camera.
Are we inhabiting Patrice’s or Anna’s
ghost, back from the dead to spook her?
Or are we her grief, threatening to overwhelm
her?
Some critics have argued that this scene actually
depicts Julie’s call to action.
It’s the first indication that her salvation
will come through helping Olivier finish the symphony.
By the time she finally agrees to work on
the composition at the end of the film, we
can even think of the symphony as a metaphor
for Julie herself.
Just like her, it’s a bit of a mess.
And only by bringing it to life is Julie able
to find some measure of peace.
When she first starts working on the composition,
Kieślowski gives us a close-up of the notes
on the page.
As Julie’s finger moves along them, we hear
the music indicated by the notes.
Then she starts suggesting changes and we hear the
new musical arrangement.
It’s a remarkable moment that plays beautifully
with this gap between diegetic and non-diegetic
sound, as we hear the score that Julie imagines.
Not only that, we hear it getting better
at the same time that Julie herself is getting better.
Georgina Evans, a film scholar at the University
of Cambridge, has a unique reading of Blue
that explores the film’s intense identification
with Julie’s subjective experience.
Evans suggests that maybe Julie experiences
synesthesia, a “neural condition in which
a stimulus to one sense produces a response
in one or more others.”
In other words, maybe Julie sees music and
hears color.
So when the symphony plays over emotional
moments, or when a new shade of blue washes
over her face, perhaps that’s how Julie
processes the world around her.
This interpretation may also give new meaning
to one of the most interesting shots near
the end of the film.
When Julie finally gives in and helps Olivier
complete the symphony, the sequence ends with
a wide shot of them that goes out of focus,
and then stays that way for a long time.
We hear Julie and Olivier, but we only see
them as fuzzy shapes deep within the frame.
It’s as if Julie needs enter some sort of
blurry mental state and let her senses fully
merge in order to create.
Finally, it’s worth noting that this film
links Julie to the music in a very literal way.
Music doesn’t really exist with only one
note.
As a karaoke singing demon once said...
Lorne: It's like a song. Now, I can hold a note for a long time.
Lorne: Actually, I can hold a note forever.
Lorne: But, eventually, that's just noise. It's the change we're listening for.
Lorne: The note coming after and the one after that. That's what makes it music.
And the same is true here.
Julie suffers, as a single person — or note
— in isolation.
But as she collaborates on the symphony and
connects with more people, more notes and
more variations of those notes appear.
The score grows right along with Julie.
So Blue could be about isolation as a coping
mechanism for grief, the ability of music
to save us, or even a woman whose senses are
scrambled.
Anchored by one of the great performances
of the end of the 20th century, this film
uses camera, lighting, and sound to tell a
difficult story with compassion and resonance.
Next time, we’ll trade Paris for Mongolia
to witness a real teenage girl’s attempt
to master an ancient tradition and bear the
title Eagle Huntress.
Crash Course Film Production is produced in
association with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check
out a playlist of their latest amazing shows, like
Origin of Everything, Deep Look, and Eons.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio
with the help of these nice people and our
amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.